this video is sponsored by nordvpn go to
nordvpn.com tflight to protect your
privacy and security on the internet
today
how do you create a sound for something
that doesn't exist
we we were desperate not to have the
audience feel like it sounded like a
helicopter
say your oscar-winning sound designer
Mark Mangini and you get tasked with
designing the sound of the orange
Founders these strange flying crafts
from the world of Doom
the sound of a real world helicopter
seems like the logical starting place
and those were the early experiments we
played with but everything that landed
on the picture felt like it was a
helicopter so we needed to kind of
divorce ourselves from believable or
realistic technology and go in another
Direction but this job gets even more
complicated because all of them were
made Believe It or Not out of
traditional organic acoustic sounds we
used very very little electronic or
synthetic sound in this film out of 3
500 bespoke sounds that we made only
three or four were made with
synthesizers part of Denise pitch to us
was that he wanted Dune to sound like a
documentary
as if we had landed on Iraqis with a
boom pole and a recorder and everything
you heard would sound like or feel like
what you'd expect it to sound like
so whatever sound you're creating for
the ornithoppers you have to use real
world recordings as your starting Place
one of the things I find magical about
sound design is the often beautifully
abstract whining path that sound
designers might take to get to the end
result how did Pablo Picasso find a way
to make a portrait out of squares and
circles those abstract Impressionists
found ways to create art with objects
that weren't what they were trying to
express but found a way to mold them to
do just that sound designers we think an
abstract ways and our brains have been
trained over the years to find
abstractions of what we want and and
create associations this is how our
sound designer brains think recently I
got the chance to chat with Mark Mangini
Who besides Dune has worked on Blade
Runner 2049 Mad Max Fury Road and a
bunch of other incredible sounding
movies we talked about the art of sound
design recording and he and his co-sound
designer Theo Green's collaboration with
director denivel news I asked him what
one of his most satisfying recent
Creations was and he told me about what
went into making the sound of the
ornithopters the really the operative
sounds that we built the ornithopters
out of for their certainly their
propulsion system are cat purrs
we had this idea that cat purring had
that
flutterings on and we were desperate to
create a fluttering because it's wings
it's not a rotor yeah we also recorded a
live beetle and captured its fluttering
wings and the real meat of the flapping
is the sound of a canvas strap of a tent
in a hundred mile an hour wind so it's
going
and then it was a process of
manipulating that very steady state
sound
so that it could accelerate decelerate
pass by with Doppler shift
and and Crews at altitude so it was
taking these actually three very steady
state sounds that had very little
Dynamics in them and building them and
shaping them to match the action of the
ornithopters
they sound great and it's it's so
immediately believable like it just
sounds like oh that's what that's what
they sound like there's no ah you said
that the imagination oh you you just you
just made a best friend to hear from
someone who doesn't know how we did it
or what we did to say oh that's exactly
what it should sound like yeah when we
achieve that that's that's Nirvana I
mean I win can end this interview now
foreign
sound design doesn't just deliver
dialogue and sound effects for what's
happening on screen it has so much
potential as a storytelling device all
while it can disappear and feel almost
Inseparable from what we're seeing
Dune and Blade Runner 2049 are two of my
favorite sounding films ever
[Music]
there's so much interesting luscious
dense sound design without it feeling
overbearing and in a way that always
expands our understanding of the world
of those films
often
sound in an instant can say something
about a character a situation a scene
have dramatic Import in ways that
Exposition is less efficient with I was
fascinated by this idea of the ambient
soundscape being able to act as
Exposition but what does that even look
like we'll get to an example in a moment
but for now bear with me while I nerd
out about one aspect of this kind of
sound design I find really cool the
background ambient soundscape for a
scene is one area of sound design that
the audience is almost never going to
consciously notice but there's still a
lot of care and Artistry that goes into
even this seemingly minuscule part of a
scene if you've never done this kind of
sound design before you might assume
that if you have a scene that happens in
a city you can just slap some City
Ambience on the scene and call it a day
but if you're trying to find background
sound that sounds believable for the
scene you'll quickly find it's a little
more complicated than that
listen how different the sound of Los
Angeles is
compared to
the sound of New York the kinds of
sounds that exist in the environment
like types of Transportation or birds
are different from location to location
but also the landscape itself the height
and shape of the buildings affects the
way the noises in the environment sound
in a place like New York there's a lot
more Reverb because the sound is
literally trapped inside the skyscrapers
bouncing around but even within a single
City where you're located is going to
affect the sound as well New York from
the perspective of the street is going
to sound very different from New York
from the perspective of an elevated
apartment Window naturally if you're
working on a scene that's set in a real
world location you can just go to that
City and record actual Ambience from
that place or you can pull one from a
sound Library
but what if you're creating an ambient
soundscape for a fictional world like
the ones we see in Dune and Blade Runner
in these cases you get to design an
ambient soundscape and that presents a
unique storytelling opportunity
Mark used this scene from Blade Runner
2049 as an example of what that can
actually look like
we knew from the script
the lower class lived on the lower
floors and as you moved up in height
you had to spend more money to live
higher and higher and higher above those
of lesser means below you so when you
start out in the bottom floor of that
building the atmospheric sounds are are
very cacophonous there's adverts blaring
At You commercials and horns honking and
the equivalent of futuristic traffic
like you would hear in any big city but
by the time you get to the top floor
foreign
[Music]
you are not hearing any of that
cacophony and in fact you are being
importuned by these very languid
soft-spoken Korean adverts beckoning you
to some like spa or something something
that would be expensive and reassuring
and peaceful and and everything in
between and Kaye who lives somewhere
above the ground floor but below the
Upper Floor had something in the Middle
where you heard a small amount of
city-like futuristic traffic flying by
through a muted window you heard some of
those public address announcements but
much more peaceful than the ones you
heard on the ground floor we built a
universe with sound that has an internal
logic to it that we try to stick to to
help further the story ideas
our ears ability to pick up on these
tiny details in a sound even when we're
not consciously thinking about it is a
big part of why the Dune sound team
stayed away from synthesized sound there
are a number of embedded cues in
everything that we hear in normal life
because everything that we hear lives in
an acoustic Universe every sound we hear
bounces off a tree bounces off the
street bounces off your nose as you
speak the moment the brain decodes those
embedded cues the brain checks a box
that says real anything in this movie
like cat Persian tent flaps Etc we put a
microphone on something captured it as
the ear would hear it then did some
subtle manipulation we slowed it down we
changed its pitch we modified it somehow
in its envelope to turn it into
something that you didn't recognize but
those subtle oral cues are still
embedded in them because they are
acoustic sounds is that a normal thing
to be able to go and do so much
recording
um for a film like that or was that more
unique to that film the goal for anyone
with integrity and sound is to record as
much fresh new sound as possible if you
want to see a Blockbuster movie and you
saw stock shot something you thought you
had seen in TV commercial it would pull
you out immediately
so too but less obviously in sound do we
strive to create new sounds even though
you know if I needed the sound of
footsteps on Sand I could go to a
library all good sound designers
Endeavor to record as much as possible
so that the movie is as bespoke and
original as possible but I have yet to
be and I'm I'm one of the luckiest on
the planet I work on some of the biggest
movies with some of the you know the
largest budgets but I've never been on a
film and I don't know anyone who has who
has been able to record everything right
right so we must rely on sound libraries
at some point I don't mean to throw any
shade on that idea because sometimes I
may want to record something new but I
can't sometimes I rely on my sound
library to find those raw elements that
I will build into something else right
Mark has been developing his own sound
library with his partner Richard
Anderson for 42 years and you can
actually look through this and license
sounds through Pro sound effects they
were gracious enough to give me some
credit so I could look around and
explore the library and it's fascinating
to listen to a lifetime of recordings
from someone who's at the top of their
game in this industry and I've been
using sound effects and soundscapes from
Mark's collection in this video
but of course the bespoke sounds you
know you I I don't sell the sounds of
worms and sinners
against the rules
for now if you want that you know you'll
have to go people will have to go record
their own cats yeah and build it build
it yourself yes
one of the things I love about both
Blade Runner 2049 and dune is the way
the soundscape and the score sometimes
seem to blend together you can't tell
where one ends and where the other
starts
instead of competing with each other
they feel like they're working together
to accomplish a common goal
Mark said that this has a lot to do with
Denise unique approach to sound Denis
empowers the sound designers to think
musically and he empowers the composer
to think sonically but you can't do that
willy-nilly you can't just send
everybody off on the road and do
everything for everything there has to
be a direction to it and this is where
you know a brilliant director like
Denise or a George Miller there's a
number of directors thinking very
intelligently like this know how to
orchestrate that so it has its um
greatest effect when you get to the
Final Mix
foreign
like this the music and the sound design
each have such an intensity that it
feels like it easily could have become a
muddled mess
[Music]
but instead these elements are all
beautifully working together there
aren't very many moments on his films
where we're recording the sound at the
very end in the Final Mix and he says I
don't like that rumbly thing I don't
like that screechy thing with most other
filmmakers you'd get to that that
sequence with the spinner crashed on the
on the sea wall and waves and Hans
Zimmer and all of that and you would
have been digging out of that for weeks
trying to figure out what's my point of
view what do I want to hear here when
Denise Villeneuve sits at a Final Mix
and we're combining dialogue music and
effects we've pretty much Road mapped
how that's all going to work long before
that so that he's making big big like
conductor-like moves of an orchestra
Denise likes to say that by the time he
gets to his final mix all the work that
I've done the sound design have become
what he calls old friends Denise heard
all the sounds he's heard the score with
the composer now he's very gently
conducting to guide us through it
just as important as sound Design's
relationship to this score is sound
Design's relationship to the edit sound
has such an influence on the edit that I
know a lot of editors who do temporary
sound design while they're editing but
Mark told me that Denis involves the
sound team earlier on in the process so
that it can work together with the edit
and in some cases even allowed the sound
design to influence the visual effects
the tradition has been you conceptualize
a shot the worms gonna breach the desert
here and it's going to travel over here
and then it's gonna go dig back into the
sand there and we'll wait six months for
that shot and we don't do any work on
that until we finally see some mock-up
of the worm do this action
well Denise and Joe recognize that
sometimes the sound itself if we build
it before the shot is realized can
inform the way the graphic artists
actually animate what we're going to see
on screen and we did that a great deal
in Dune and and it becomes this very
organic process and it gets back us back
to that very beautiful thing you said at
the very beginning which was everything
that I heard sounded exactly the way it
should sound one of the reasons it that
happens is that because all of that is
happening organically and symbiotically
in ways that are very non-traditional
sound design usually is something that
happens after the edit is done the
visual effects are done often the score
is even done and we don't have any input
into how all of that happened denee does
this a very different way I think the
beauty and Artistry of sound design can
sometimes get overlooked because it can
feel like it plays a more utilitarian
role in filmmaking and sometimes it is
but it can also take on a sort of
avant-garde musicality as well the first
meeting
I had with Denise Villeneuve we watched
the movie and we're wrapping it wrapping
it up and he said to Theo and I I want
you to compose with sound and he meant
that in every possible way you can
interpret it this idea of sound itself
as music I think is really interesting
and one that Mark Mangini carries into
his work I feel sorry for co-posers
because they only have 12 notes to work
with I have an unlimited Universe of
sound to work that's my palette
music as most of us traditionally
understand it to me is a very
constrained and organized version of
sound in one little pocket of what is a
wardrobe of of sound that can be
expressed and heard my everyday life is
spent deconstructing everything that I
hear I'm constantly analyzing what I
hear and wondering where it comes from
how distant is it from me what might be
making that sound how could I mimic that
sound what does it sound like I'm always
pulling everything I'm pulling sound
apart just as a writer pours emotion
into every word that's in a screenplay
or script or a book so too does a sound
designer
pour those same intentions into the
building of sounds anytime sound design
is fun and is engaging and is immersive
I don't mean immersive in the technical
sense of you have to have speakers
around you I mean immersive much more so
in the sense of
when we feel immersed in something we
feel fully engaged
the movie has grabbed a hold of us and
convinced us of its believability
when sound can do that and capture the
audience and make them feel like they
are on that alien planet or they're
experiencing that emotion with the
protagonist or that fear
that's really powerful sound design
if you're like me and you're balancing
like 12 different streaming services it
can be really tempting to just come up
with weak passwords for each of those or
reuse the same password again and again
and you've probably heard that you
shouldn't do this but you might not know
why hackers can do something called
credential stuffing where they take
those passwords from the breach and use
them everywhere else the best way to
protect yourself from this is by just
using a unique strong password for every
website but let's be honest most of us
are not doing that well so you can add
an additional layer of protection by
using nordvpn's dark web monitoring this
video is sponsored by nordvpn you can go
to nordvpn.com tflight to get a discount
off of the two-year plan nordvpn is an
excellent VPN with a ton of really fast
servers and it's very easy to use on a
bunch of devices but it also comes with
a bunch of additional security features
that can protect you on the internet
like the dark web monitoring which looks
through the dark web to see if your
information is out there and then can
alert you you can take extra steps to
protect your account vpns are just a
crucial part of open and free access to
the internet whether you need to get
around Geo blocking or protect your own
privacy it's an important tool to have
in your toolkit as an internet user I've
been using nordvpn for years and it's
been helping to keep me safe secure and
protect my privacy on the internet for a
long time you can sign up by going to
nordvpn.com tflight or by clicking the
link in the description when you use my
link you'll get a big discount off of
the two-year plan a free month and you
get access to the 30-day money-back
guarantee so you can try nordvpn
completely risk-free again that's
nordvpn.comtflight or click the link in
the description to sign up today and get
a discount off of nordvpn start
protecting your privacy and security on
the internet with nordvpn
foreign
[Music]